on this vote the yeas are 192 nays are
213 the bill does not pass the house
freedom caucus flex some muscle helping
defeat a five-year farm bill defying GOP
leaders and President Trump the
conservatives demanded a vote on a
security focused immigration plan before
the farm bill with some moderate
Republicans signing on with Democrats to
force a vote on addressing daca the
young people brought to this country
illegally by their parents conservatives
say this became an emergency I would say
that the farm bill doesn't expire until
September so we have plenty of time to
do the farm bill but if this discharge
petition comes we're going to be dealing
with that imminently next month so it's
more important right now to prioritize
immigration and we've been asking and
waiting for months House GOP leaders put
the farm bill on the floor calling the
freedom caucuses bluff the package
includes policy changes favored by the
president and the speaker including
having able-bodied food stamp recipients
work or receive job training the bill
can be brought up again when leadership
is confident they have the votes well
sure it's disappointed we need to move
forward on a farm bill the Republicans
want to move forward on the reforms to
the food stamp program the food stamps
provision kept Democrats unified in
their opposition to the farm bill the
Agriculture committees top Democrat says
easing the work requirements could help
deliver votes from his side the whole
problem was food stamps
and it could have been worked out I'm
not happy to sale you know I I'm not
happy we're in this situation but I'm
willing to do what I can to try to fix
it the White House says the president is
disappointed and hopes the house can
resolve remaining issues in order to
achieve strong work requirements and
support the nation's agricultural
community